is it a parallel universe where you're
hosting Meet the Press I think there
should be but it'd be like in that Star
Trek episode whenever there's a parallel
universe right the people in the other
universe have little goatees like Spock
has a goatee and you know everyone has a
slight difference so I think there's a
parallel universe where I host Meet the
Press but I have a little goatee and
slightly evil eyebrows I think you're
gonna give me an answer about your
political proclivities and why actually
you know yes why you could have pursued
that route and you know if you could
only go back but no instead you have a
goatee and different eyebrows yes okay
cool yeah we're not gonna waste your
time with you know I mean do some
curiosity about that stuff in a way that
would I do I have a lot of curiosity I
mean I I think you and I are both
curious Souls you
I think you've asked me as many
questions today as I've asked you most
people are content to let me do all the
questioning right you you are a curious
man I'm a curious man I think there's an
alternate universe where you and I have
like a very sophisticated like
huntley-brinkley this is a very old
reference kids but look it up kind of
show you and I are dissecting the
national discourse yeah every night and
people really admire us right sure but
then you're vaguely aware that you have
a big movie career in another universe
and you're pretty pumped about that yeah
your bet you're pissed that you're not
in there right that I'm not in that one
yeah but this goatee yeah and you have a
weird goatee yeah yeah and I'm actually
happy that I'm in the universe I meant
cause I'm getting a break from my family
this is fascinating we're both aware of
our parallel lives but one person is
happy to be in this other situation and
the other person laments the fact that
they're in this body I'm happy that I'm
in the other universe because my
cholesterol is slightly lower there
today right right right you know my
cholesterol is like a solid 130 right
it's a nanny in the in the universe from
Conan O'Brien the the talk-show host
comedian it's pushing 200 right right my
hair does better in humidity and the
other body for exactly yeah again were
you and I to take a long car trip sure I
think I think they be a few hours where
we're the closest of friends sure and
then I think as we started to get out to
the Badlands you think we'd make it to
the Badlands yes and flattered thank you
honored
we get to the Badlands I think I would
contrive away sorry we going west to
east or east to west east to west is how
I would lettering thank you yeah we get
all the way to the Badlands I'm sorry
the Badlands of Massachusetts Oh got it
it's an area Western Massachusetts yeah
it's just not a good neighborhood yeah
yeah but anyway I think yeah I think I
might contrive a way to to lure you into
the woods and thanks try and end you
sure sure sure sure
I think you'd win but I'd bite you're a
biter yeah uh it's kind of silly but if
we get one thing out of this I would
love to have your address not here on
the air yeah but you are a you're a a
great fellow I have a lot of admiration
for you
and I would like to occasionally write
you a stupid note oh thank you and so if
that happens I'll shred it you will
shred